[Music]
as of today I've been on two thousand
thirty different roller coasters
[Applause]
and I've been on 2047 different
rollercoasters and that's at 773
different amusement parks in 36
different countries on five different
continents
[Music]
there it is
I'm gonna see where it's pretty cool a
Martin Louison and I'm Cheryl Lewisohn
and we are roller coaster and these work
enthusiasts
[Music]
we Center I would say 90% of our travel
on theme parks
we just landed at the Detroit Airport
it's day one of our trip
we're gonna hit five parts to it the way
we keep track of how many roller
coasters we've ridden is using the app
coaster - count calm and I've gone to
the rankings page were both in the top
time in the world currently Cheryl ranks
number six and I ranked number eight
first Park is CJ Barrymore's it's an MVC
[Music]
for a family entertainment center that's
a huge pharisee I'm a professor of
business management and I'm an emergency
physician
we both had pretty high pressure jobs so
we found that we could get on a plane
and spend a weekend at a theme park and
have an amazing time that's kind of how
it started the ranking for how many
rollercoasters we've ridden means
everything it's why we do this what year
was CJ Barrymore is established 1974 you
looked so when we plan it post a trip we
usually sit down and map out how many
parks we can fit in in one day based on
how much time we want to spend there and
the opening hours and how far they are
from each other we're just gonna go for
the coaster right now because because we
we've got other other parts to visit
today but we get it typically we'll come
in we'll take some photos
nice ride the coaster and then we'll
leave takes 15 minutes people who count
roller coasters
refer to roller coasters as credits
credit so oh I went to such-and-such
theme park did you get the new credit
meaning did you ride the new roller
coaster one park down before to go
[Music]
okay so here's the current t-shirt
collection so this is Belmont Park in
San Diego this is turbulence from
Adventureland on Long Island the comet
lightning rod beach bend Kings Dominion
the Thunderbolt eventually you know you
run out of domestic places in you
circling elsewhere fry shoots in Germany
and this is Universal Studios Singapore
this is Hyperion mega coaster that was
my 2000 coaster in Poland there's China
and China we've written 248 coasters and
they're still 884 eight trips to China
and we've made hardly made a dent like
crazy okay let's go
so this is our second Park of the day it
does look good
[Music]
we're having some good years let's go
ride another roller coaster Oh manual
push maybe the most we've ever done in a
year would be like 120 parks and we're
certainly on pace to hit that this year
or even beat it credit an hour and 40
minutes to get from Kokomo's to Cedar
Valley's wild frontier park fun wild
frontier fun park i like height height
and speed those are the two big things
can we fit yeah some rollercoasters are
thrilling
we prefer good rollercoasters over bad
rollercoasters but we've signed up for
this quantity over quality hobby some of
our acquaintances out there in the
roller coaster enthusiasts world they're
happy to mock us for riding utter crap
not bad at all
terrible roller coasters or writing
children's roller coasters which we do a
lot of Cheryl you're awesome but there's
something about driving that extra three
hours to visit that little theme park
that no one's ever been to to ride there
a little roller coaster that no one else
is ridden
there's something about that what's a
little chilly yeah okay we're at the
last Park of the day we have one roller
coaster here which will be our fifth on
the day Hey
thank you so much credit all right we
did it
five parks one day there was no roller
coaster anything in our meeting in our
engagement in our marriage like nothing
no roller coaster stuff it wasn't until
a year after we got married that we
realized we both loved going to
amusement parks and we both loved roller
coasters
I think this passion for roller coasters
has definitely brought us closer
together it's sure when you're like
going around a curve and you smooshed on
one side five out of five way to go
[Music]
you coming I'm coming it's day two
it's a tough agenda for our drive to
start the morning so yes we enjoy
travelling this way Christ cruisers Oh
pizza buffet look I found the credit we
understand that it's crazy in a lot of
different ways but also we get to rub
shoulders with people from many
different cultures and wait in hot
sweaty lines with them for hours to get
on a roller coaster that we all can
scream on together
[Music]
[Music]
hey Cheryl you really rode the hell out
of those rollercoasters today nice job
way to go why do you have to always make
it physical I'm just kidding
[Music]
hey Cheryl come on let's go ride more
rollercoasters this is day three our
first stop of the day is Santa's Village
azuz Minh Park it's two hours and 40
minutes drive it does become part of
your identity that you're like oh one of
the most well traveled roller coaster
enthusiasts out there so there's some
pride built in there but I also know
that it's not the Nobel Prize let's go
[Music]
say cheese cheese
are we allowed to stay here all day they
only have another park to get food we
have to go to another park Six Flags
Great America this is our last stop look
at that beauty
[Music]
he told me when we got to a thousand you
would stop so I was looking forward to
that and then we kept going and now I
want to get to the next level
[Music]
most of our family approves or they
think it's fun and cool we're never
gonna win over my dad though he just
thinks it's utter silliness how is this
hobby affected our relationship I think
about how lucky we are but we both have
this joint passion we're partners
we're writing partners it's been the
glue in our relationship yeah we
actually have a picture we were writing
the same great wooden roller coaster
over and over again Kentucky rumbler
yeah a beach boom
each time we wanted the picture of us
kissing and we couldn't get it right
until we wrote and wrote and wrote and
wrote until we had the perfect picture
of us kissing on the ride we just want
to keep writing until we die and then
we'll be done
[Music]
you